sehr geehrte damen und herren
pandemie haben wir gelernt dass
transparenz hilft missverständnisse zu
vermeiden
deswegen haben wir uns entschlossen so
schnell wie möglich mit dem rk ii vor
die presse zu treten
ich bin auch ärztepräsident rheine hat
sehr dankbar dass er sich heute in
bremen dazu gesät und auch stellung
nehmen wird so dass wir zunächst ein
paar missverständnisse ausräumen können
und dann auch ihren fragen begegnen
können zunächst das missverständnis
nummer eins was wir mit den affen
brocken gerade erleben ist nicht der
beginn einer neuen pandemie von allem
was wir wissen
hat es ausbrüche dieser viruserkrankung
schon sehr häufig gegeben und sie kann
durch gute kontakt nachverfolgung und
vorsicht auch gut in den griff bekommen
werden somit also sind wir hier nicht am
vorabend einer neuen pandemie sondern
wir haben es hier mit ausbrüchen zu tun
die an bekannten erreger betreffen und
wo wir wissen wie wir diesen erreger
bekämpfen können im wesentlichen mit
sogenannten public health maßnahmen die
gleiche ausgeführt werden das müsst euch
dennis nummer zwei ist dass man ja von
talking drum nicht wirklich ernst nehmen
wo ist dass es auch falsch denn wir
wissen jetzt noch nicht weshalb die
ausbrüche international diesmal so
anders verlaufen als in der
vergangenheit das haus hier ist es
möglich
dass entweder der erreger sich verändert
hat oder dass die also
anfälligkeit der menschen sich für den
erreger verändert hat und es gibt auch
noch andere möglichkeiten somit also ist
hier unsere aufgabe die dass wir die
ausbrüche früh eindämmen denn wenn wir
die ausbrüche früh eindämmen doch die
möglichkeit zu erreichen dass sich diese
erreger nicht beim menschen einnistet
und wir somit ein endemische sun
nennenswertes indem ich es geschehen
aufbauen daher also muss man schnell
reagieren und das missverständnis nummer
drei ist dass es nur diejenigen
betreffen würde die ungeschützten sex
mit unbekannten hatten das stimmt zwar
für bestimmte homosexuelle männer
beispielsweise sexarbeiter dass die
jetzt im moment stärker betroffen sind
aber der erreger kann auch zum beispiel
kinder betreffen er kann wie alle
geschlechter betreffen er kann kinder
erwachsene jugendliche betreffen und wir
wissen das in zentralafrika die variante
die dort also üblich ist dass diese
sogar eine sterblichkeit von bis zu elf
prozent bei kindern unter 16 jahren
haben kann somit muss man das ganze
schon ernst nehmen und wir müssen
reagieren
zu einem zeitpunkt wo die fallzahl noch
niedrig ist der wichtigste schritt dafür
ist information wir müssen uns zunächst
einmal die risikogruppen die wir derzeit
können gezielt ansprechen diese risi die
hauptrisikogruppe zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
sind männer die ungefähr so sex mit
anderen männern gehabt haben
und das muss man ansprechen kann um
diese gruppe zu schützen zum eigenen
schutz der gruppe das ist keine
stigmatisierung hier handelt es sich
lediglich um die beschreibung der
derzeitigen risikogruppe und auch diese
risikogruppe kann ich ja nur schützen
indem ich die risikogruppe auch
ansprüche direkt anspreche
vorurteilsfrei ohne stigmatisierung und
ich habe ja schon darauf hingewiesen
dass kann auch ganz anderer gruppen in
zukunft betreffen so dass wir neue
risikogruppen dann hätten das wollen wir
aber da verhindern deshalb müssen wir
reagieren war der reaktion gilt das
gesetz was auch jetzt in genf bei der
weltgesundheitsversammlung noch einmal
diskutiert wurde in den frühen phase
also
epidemie muss hart und früher reagiert
werden daher haben wir mit den ländern
heute eine empfehlung
entwickelt die wir den ländern für die
umsetzung ans herz legen wollen
kernbestandteil ist dass diejenigen die
infiziert sind sich für mindestens 21
tage isolieren sollen das soll es an
isolations anordnung geben für
mindestens 21 tage und also
symptomfreiheit weil wir wissen was die
infektion auch über den 21 sonntag
hinaus noch möglich dann bleiben die
kosten die sich dann typischerweise
gebildet haben noch weiter ansteckend
somit also ist hier eine isolation von
mindestens 21 tage und spät und
mindestens bis zum abfahren der kosten
notwendig ebenso soll es eine strenge
empfehlung eine dringende empfehlung für
die
kontaktpersonen geben die unmittelbaren
kontaktpersonen und der wähler wird
gleich aus führen wir das genau ist für
ebenfalls 21 tage so dass wir mit
isolation und quarantäne von mindestens
21 tage das früher ausbruchsgeschehen in
den griff bekommen können darüber hinaus
wollen wir auch also den schutz aufbauen
so die bevölkerung fast das geschehen
der exo sich weiter ausbreitet wollen
wir vorbereitet sein auf mögliche zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt noch nicht also
empfohlen aber mögliche eventuell
notwendige ring impfungen das heißt um
den infizierten herum werden dann die
kontakte geben wir haben einen impfstoff
bestellt bis zu 40.000 dosen im vaneks
der also für die
bekämpfung der affen brocken in den
vereinigten staaten zugelassen ist und
auch in deutschland werden können würde
dieser impfstoff kann genutzt werden um
eine ansteckung zu verhindern aber auch
bei den angesteckten bereits
angesteckten den ausbruch der erkrankung
verhindern oder zumindest verzögern ist
verzögern und ich rechne damit dass wir
also hier eine reserve in kürze
geliefert bekommen das ist zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt noch nicht klar ob wir den
impfstoff so einsetzen müssen kopien zum
beispiel bei kindern als kontaktperson
einsetzen können oder müssen das wissen
wir noch nicht das wird mit dem robert
koch institut aber auch mit dem paul
ehrlich institut sehr intensiv
besprochen schließlich ich bin im
täglichen austausch auch in dieser sache
mit dem robert-koch-institut und auch
mit den kolleginnen und kollegen von der
europäischen sed behörde die hier also
an rescap wesel gestern 14 uhr möglich
gemacht hat und die sich sehr intensiv
damit beschäftigt wie diese ausbrüche in
europa verhindert werden können wir sind
auch sehr eng mit dem austausch ich
glaube dass wir noch sehr gute chancen
haben diese diesen erreger zu stoppen
nicht nur in deutschland zu stoppen
sondern in ganz europa zu stoppen dafür
machen wir derzeit alles wie reagieren
hart und schnell und werden also nicht
zulassen dass hier die reaktion
verschleppt wird
herzlichen dank herr professor wieder
bitte
ok guten tag meine damen ist auch grün
werder bremen das passt ja gut also in
den letzten tagen sind einige fälle von
affen brocken aufgetreten und zwar in
einer vielzahl von ländern wie wir das
bislang noch nicht gesehen hatten
momentan der stand ist von 11 uhr heute
morgen sind uns bekannt 177 fälle in 16
ländern die mehrheit und das ist sie
besonders hat keine aktuelle reise
geschichte in ein endemische gebiet
diese affen brocken kommen ja in
zentralafrikanischen staaten vor und in
westafrika und es handelt sich bei den
meisten fällen um männer die sex mit
männern hatten
tatsächlich ist das erste mal dass wir
infektionsketten in europa beobachten
ohne einen epidemiologischen link zu
endemischen regionen zu haben das ist
das bemerkenswerte wir haben deshalb
anfang der letzten woche die ärzteschaft
und verschiedene verbände darauf
hingewiesen dass sie achtsam sind und
patienten die symptome haben rasch zum
arzt gehen um die abklären zu lassen und
wir bringen damit auch in zusammenhang
dass nur die ersten patienten in
deutschland auch gefunden wurden und
sich aktiv bei ärzten vorgestellt haben
der erste fall war am 22 05 das war in
münchen heute der stand ist der aktuell
vor einer stunde dass wir fünf fälle
bislang 1 robert koch institut
übermittelt wurden es sind alle fünf
männer und drei davon gehen wir davon
aus nach dem jetzigen wissen dass sie im
ausland exponiert waren bei zwei fällen
wurde der explosionsort in deutschland
angegeben die betroffene person klagen
über symptome wie fieber sie haben
lymphknotenschwellungen im hautausschlag
hautläsionen das ist ja das typische
starke schmerzen teilweise auch im
intimbereich jucken und allgemeine
krankheitszeichen auch erschöpfung
was wissen
seltene viruserkrankungen und sie wird
vermutlich vor allen dingen von
nagetieren auf den menschen übertragen
das hat sich also um eine zoonose wieder
mal eine zoonose wie wir sie auch
erwarten etwa dreiviertel oder zwei
drittel aller krankheiten die wir
menschen haben sind durch 2000
hervorrufen also letztlich vom tier auf
den menschen übertragen wurden die affen
packen können durch einen engen kontakt
mit einer infizierten person oder auch
einem infizierten tier oder auch durch
kontaminiertes material auf menschen
übertragen werden sie werden aufgelöst
durch das auf dem pockenvirus monkey box
virus wird das auch in literatur genannt
oder mpx v und das ist aus der gattung
der otto programmieren dass dieses virus
ist verwandt mit den klassischen human
pockenviren aber es ist eben nicht
zumal pockenvirus nicht dass es hier zu
missverständnissen kommt sie sind in
west und zentralafrika
vorwiegend bei nagetieren verbreitet und
tatsächlich wurde erstmals er vor 52
jahren 1970 in kongo in der republik
kongo in der demokratischen republik
kongo zum ersten mal wurden diese
brocken bei einem menschen nachgewiesen
bei einem neun monate alten kind wir
kennen das virus erst seit 1958 uns also
auch gar nicht so lange 2003 kam es
tatsächlich zum ersten nachweis von
affen pocken außerhalb des afrikanischen
kontinents das war damals in den
vereinigten staaten durch den import von
bestimmten ratten affen brocken sind in
der regel und das ist die gute nachricht
einer selbst limitierende krankheit von
der sich die meisten menschen innerhalb
weniger wochen erholen dennoch kann es
eben bei einigen personen auch eine
schwere erkrankung auftreten nicht der
lauterbach nannte gerade ein paar zahlen
dazu sind leicht von menschen die nicht
leicht von mensch zu mensch zu
übertragen und deshalb schätzt dass sie
die sie dass wir haben das wochenende
gemeinsam also viele kollegen aus europa
war auch vom rk ii haben wir ein so
genanntes risk assessment erarbeitet
dass es gestern um 14 uhr auf die
website gestellt worden das easy dies
schätzt das risiko für die allgemeine
bevölkerung gering ein das gesamtrisiko
für personen mit mehreren sexualpartnern
wird vom sed sie als moderat
eingeschätzt und die wahrscheinlichkeit
dass sich affen brocken bei personen mit
mehreren sexualpartnern ausbreiten die
ist hoch dass die einschätzung die sie
beim jetzigen ausbruchs wurden vor allen
dingen männer diagnostiziert die sex mit
männern haben also msm aber dass auch
hatte
minister lauterbach zu recht noch einmal
klar gemacht dass wir es kann natürlich
unabhängig von der sexuellen
orientierung auf jeden übertragen werden
unabhängig vom geschlecht vom alter aber
eine gefährdung für die gesundheit der
allgemeinen bevölkerung in deutschland
wird eben nach derzeitigen erkenntnissen
als gering eingeschätzt
es ist aber klar dass weitere fälle in
deutschland zu erwarten sind unser ziel
ist es deshalb den ausbruch einzudämmen
das kann eben nur gelingen wenn wir zum
eine erfolgreiche kontakt nachverfolgung
machen da kennen sie sich inzwischen
glaube ich alle sehr sehr gut aus wie
das funktioniert vermeiden von engen
kontakten zu infizierten personen so
viele gene maßnahmen beim umgang mit
infizierten das bleibt natürlich der
beste schutz aber dafür müssen eben
diejenigen die halt unter risiko stehen
müssen darüber informiert sein sie
müssen wachsam rhein zum arzt gehen und
sich selber eben auch 18 verhalten die
inkubationszeit ist eine literatur
angaben zwischen 5 und 21 tagen daher
kommt auch diese frist von 21 tagen über
für die quarantäne empfehlen nach jetzt
im kenntnis haben sich die meisten
personen von diesen 177 auf großen
veranstaltungen angesteckt die mit
sexuellen aktivitäten verbunden waren
beim auftreten von einem ungewöhnlichen
ausschlag oder läsionen oder wenn ein
verdacht auf affen pocken besteht
sollten eben wirklich unmittelbar
ärztliche hilfe aufgesucht werden um in
die infektionsketten zu brechen
empfiehlt der ak ii manches klingt schon
wecker gestellt sind eine isolierung bis
zum abfall der kosten aber mindestens
von 21 tagen und für enge kontakte
empfehlen wir eine quarantäne von 21
ebenfalls meine damen und herren wir
befinden uns in einem frühen stadium
dieses ausbruchs und vieles ist auch
noch unbekannt aber wir beobachten die
lage weiterhin sehr genau und passe
natürlich die empfehlungen den aktuellen
wissenstand an sie finden alle aktuellen
informationen die website glaube gerade
heute gegen 12 uhr haben wir die in der
faq auf die website gestellt die sind
immer aktualisiert bitte gehen sie auf
die webseite schauen sich die infos an
dankeschön
herzlichen dank der professor will herr
dr einhandelte ja ich würde das meiste
das so ist gesagt ich teile ausdrücklich
vorgehensweise der minister leider vage
skizziert hat die finde ich
100-prozentig richtige würden wir 11
ähnlich und genauso empfehlen wir werden
unseren teil in dem was die
informationen des aks angeht was das
gesamte prozedere die seitens des
ministeriums angeht selbst
wahrscheinlich ärzteschaft entsprechend
informieren auch anhalten sich in diesen
situationen text einzubeziehen und
entsprechend zu handeln also auch darauf
zu achten dass achtsamkeit unklare
befunde und so weiter und so fort in
diesem kontext auch bewertet werden ich
mache vielleicht auch zwei dinge aus
medizinischer sicht aufmerksam auch
flächen dialog ich glaube dies die lange
denkbar lange inkubationszeit bei
unfällen ein gewisses problem darstellt
weil die hand der kontakt gehabt hat
natürlich unter umständen bis zu drei
wochen lang symptomlos sein kann und
dennoch infiziert ist und vielleicht
eben auch infektiös ist das ist ja nicht
total sicher zu wissen aber trotzdem
muss man das in betracht ziehen und
insofern glaube ich muss man sich
überlegen ob man die kontakte
nachverfolgung und derjenigen die
infiziert sind im hinblick auf
vielleicht auch post- express- impfungen
sich vorstellen kann dass das eine odere
zweite ist wo wir dann auch mal
hinweisen möchte das haben sie aber
schon beschrieben er wieder dass die
auch in der vergangenheit die sie schon
aufgetreten ist und es bisher eigentlich
immer gelungen ist ist erfolgreich
einzudämmen
also sozusagen im umgang mit dieser
erkrankung was ihre kollegialität
übertragungsweg und auch die
möglichkeiten von installationen angeht
ich glaube weil gute chancen hat wenn
man jetzt sehr frühzeitig hat handelt
dafür zu sorgen dass es eben nicht so
dynamischen situation kommt
herzlichen dank wir kommen zu ihren
fragen wir haben leider keine mikros
hier aber das kriegen wir schon hin
bitte
ich glaube bei ihnen ist das ein anderes
thema da kommen wir gleich zu
keiner eine frage zum an keyboards
bitteschön
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt ist die regen
impfung nur also ein konzept ist wird
noch nicht empfohlen wir haben den stoff
wir besorgen neben stoff prophylaktisch
hier geht es darum dass man schnell
handelt denn wenn die ausbrüche
weitergehen würden dann müssten wir
natürlich unser konzept anpassen und
dann könnte an der regen in form
tatsächlich auch eine rolle spielen zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt ist es nicht geplant
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt arbeiten wir nur
mit den methoden die er wieder gerade
vorgetragen hat dass wir die menschen
isolieren und den charakter bringen das
konzept der impfung würde dann
beispielsweise zum tragen kommen wenn
eine person sich infiziert hat und lebt
in also einem umfeld von menschen die
besonders gefährdet sind beispielsweise
immunsupprimierten und dergleichen dann
könnte man die prophylaktisch impfen um
also zu verhindern falls sie sich
angesteckt haben dass der ausbruch so
kommt oder dass sie so schwer erkannt
und so wurde die impfung dann eingesetzt
habe wie gesagt das ist ein konzept was
wir es hat nur
vorbereitende reinhardt hat es ebenfalls
wieder wir müssen vorbereitet zahlen und
daher möchte ich nicht in einer
situation kommen
ein solches konzept würde es notwendig
werden dann sagen müssen wir haben im
stoff
also der was war der erste punkt noch
einmal die zweite punkt war
ach so wie die immunität genau genau es
ist davon auszugehen dass diejenigen die
also gegen pocken also geimpft worden
sind und da war die also impfung ja die
pflichtimpfung
ausgelaufen
noch also
in den späten 70er jahren und also ich
glaube in der früheren ddr es bis 82
geimpft worden in dieses richtig in
erinnerung habe somit also diejenigen
die noch die impfungen damals bekommen
habe hast du noch weniger gm vor die
durften gegen gegen pocken
sollten die eine immunität besitzen wie
ausgeprägte immunität genau ist wissen
wir nicht wahrscheinlich ist es eine
also komplett immunität mann war es das
aber noch nicht so genau diese
impfstoffe die
poker neben stoffe die wir auch lagern
also aus sicherheitsgründen weil es zum
einen also
wieder ausgegeben könnte auch die
natürliche art und weise ist so
ausgestorben das pockenvirus aber kann
sein dass es also noch reservoirs gibt
nur zum zweiten das ist auch glaube ich
2013 oder 2014 gelungen also
menschen brocken also oder den menschen
befallen die pocken zu produzieren in
kanada in einem sehr umstrittenen
experiment daher haben wir aus
sicherheitsgründen haben wir pockenvirus
gelagerte wer aber für die bekämpfung
der affen brocken nicht geeignet weil er
mit nebenwirkungen einher gehen durfte
die also harten brocken
impfungen nicht vertretbar wären daher
also dieser impfstoff im vaneks und
internet ist in den vereinigten staaten
zugelassen ist aber hier auch für manche
box also geprüft war und somit die
unterlagen dafür
vorhanden und wir könnten diesen
impfstoff sollte es notwendig werden
unmittelbar einsetzen
ich kann das gerne noch ergänzen also
die immunität ist gegeben sie wird
natürlich immer schwächer je länger
diese impfung her ist also die konkret
ist auch einer der person
infiziert der auch eine impfung damals
hat also die immunität lässt natürlich
nach aber den das krankheitsgeschehen
wird abgemildert wir müssen immer vor
augen haben das war als er die brocken
ausgerottet haben damals und der witz
ist eben der dass diese pocken ebenen
kreuzimmunität haben zum teil mit den
affen pocken da waren vier milliarden
menschen auf der welt ja wir sind jetzt
acht milliarden menschen das heisst also
jetzt das ist natürlich in der gesamten
population ist einfach eben kaum eine
belastbare immunität und das ist auch
der grund warum viele wissenschaftler in
den letzten jahren immer wieder unter
anderem auch davor gewarnt haben dass so
ein affe pocken wir sind so eine
immunologische lücke reinkommt und
natürlich alle die nach 80 dann geboren
sind sowieso die können ja gar keine
immunität haben und die andere sache ist
leute aber spricht das genau es gibt ja
impfstoff gegen pocken der der
eingelagert ist aber wir erinnern uns
vielleicht auch noch als ich selber bin
auch noch geimpft dieser impfstoff hat
der teilweise schon ordentliche
nebenwirkungen gehabt erinnert sich die
ärzte alle ganz gut dran und darum wurde
auch das weiterentwickeln dass wegen
dieses impfstoff index von dem paar
lauter war sprach der ist eben hat
deutlich weniger nebenwirkungen das ist
ein modifiziertes ankara vakzin ja virus
das ist sehr engagiert worden in der
zellkultur eine sehr gute bonität und
eine geringe nebenwirkungen dass das
kann man eben einsätzen in dieses die
diesen impfstoff und die strategien wie
man das macht die muss man sich
überlegen und es muss eben besorgt
werden es gibt eben natürlich ist doch
klar dass gegen eine seltene krankheit
nicht riesige impfstoffmengen einfach
auf vorrat sind das ist muss man immer
wissen
wo wir kommen zu ihrer wahl
nach
es gibt also vergabestandards und diese
vergabestandards sind entwickelt worden
mit den entsprechenden
fachgesellschaften und
ist natürlich schwierig im einzelfall zu
prüfen ob also bei der anwerbung dann
diese kriterien erfüllt worden sind aber
die frage die sie mir jetzt stellen ist
abstrakt können gibt es einen fall wo
ist also aus ihrer sicht nicht also
ausreichend gesichert war
dann werde ich das sofort prüfen und
dankt ihnen für den hinweis also ich
habe mit dem gesundheitsminister
ich habe mit dem gesundheitsminister von
indonesien also noch darüber gesprochen
also wie wir sicherstellen können dass
zum einen also die quali die
qualifikationsanforderungen
eingehalten werden und wie wir auch
sicherstellen können dass menschen die
sich uns hier an vertrauen so behandelt
werden und so war bezug auf ihre
finanzierung in bezug auf ihre
lebensumstände aber auch die
arbeitsbedingungen dass wir das in jeder
hinsicht vertreten können denn das wenn
der fall mehr zur aufmerksamkeit
gebracht wird werde ich mir das genau
anschauen
wir vorne dran
vom technischen belasten
die braucht man
das
ja wir werden auf jeden fall alles tun
was wir können um zu verhindern dass
kinder erneut im art von maßnahmen
betroffen sein
müssen die also den kindern schaden und
also da sind zum beispiel
schulschließungen angesprochen oder das
schulausfall angesprochen dass sport
auswahl ausgesprochen wir müssen einfach
mehr tun um dies zu verhindern und daher
ist das auch ein schwerpunkt meiner
vorbereitung für den herbst das also
alles so vorbereitet ist dass wir
schulschließungen auf keinen fall
benötigen aber was auch sehr wichtig ist
dass wir für die kinder die hier ist im
letzten also ja betroffen gewesen sind
dass für diese kinder mehr tun dass wir
versuchen das was verloren gegangen ist
aufzuholen das wir für die kinder dafür
sorgen dass hier das schule nachgeholt
werden kann das also sich der sportstadt
findet dass sie genau eine
psychologische betreuung bekommen wir
dürfen die kinder jetzt nicht
zurücklassen die nachteilig schon gehabt
haben
die kollegen nehmen
zunächst war sie cupid medikamente da
gibt es ja wesentliche fortschritte
packt so wird beispielsweise
und andere und die haben wir ja nicht
nur das nur pressekonferenz des
bundesgesundheitsministers karl
lauterbach
21 tage isolation dafür menschen die mit
dem affen trocken virus infiziert sind
das soll empfohlen werden das ist eine
nachricht die kenne bereits aus belgien
auch dort 21 tage isolation und dennoch
fühlt es sich so an wie ein schlechter
film als würde alles irgendwie nochmal
von vorne los gehen auch wenn der
gesundheitsminister ganz klar gesagt hat
das ist nicht der der beginn einer
pandemie er sagt aber auch ganz klar ist
aber auch falsch die ihr affen pocken
nicht ernst zu nehmen dass also die
nachricht jetzt an diesem dienstag vom
gesundheitsminister